War Thunder players and Forum enjoys
just leaked sensitive government
documents again if you remember last
year users were banned left right and
Center on the War Thunder Forum for
posting sensitive military information
about weapons and vehicles but they
weren't doing this to be some sort of
fearless whistleblowers oh no like true
Gamers they were doing this to complain
about realism and game balance now
believe it or not things got even
weirder from here in the most recent
snowden-esque Endeavors a user was
banned from the Forum after posting
restricted material about F-16 fighter
jets but this time it was to wait for it
win an argument and these
just couldn't help themselves because
they continued to post more fighter jet
documents the very next day apparently
it's now gotten to the point where
defense contractors are asking about
whether potential hires are playing the
game